alrighty i tell you what's on my mind is
getting more snow in our local mountains
and getting us some more rain now the
timing may not be perfect and i
apologize for that but mother nature has
her own ideas when it comes to weather
and storms that come in but it would be
nice to have some more snow in the
mountains nice shot as we look out there
we've got some more clouds that have
been coming in too we had a little
clearing overnight and that's allowed
temperatures to drop into some chilly
30s this morning a little bit of an
inversion an inversion layer is when
some warmer air is in the higher
elevations trapping some cooler air in
the valley and that's kind of what we've
got a little bit of this morning here
are your headlines though as we're in
our holiday week now and you've got all
these plans made probably for the
weekend clouds and sunshine one more day
today this is the best day to get stuff
done and not have to worry about
navigating rain and slogging around with
an umbrella and all that chance of
showers tomorrow
into christmas eve into friday so
thursday late and thursday night into
christmas eve day and then a chance of
rain some showers off and on kind of
through christmas weekend
coming and going so not all the time and
we might even get breaks of sunshine
during christmas weekend but there are
some slight chances left for the weekend
so we've got intermountain snow moving
into the west we've got rain and snow
into the pacific northwest those are
places you want to take a coat an
umbrella san francisco's had rain this
morning eventually l.a will get rain
into thursday if you're traveling there
that could create some travel problems
for you middle of the country is just
darn cold we're talking teens and 20s
from minneapolis down to kansas city 20
in chicago and cold around the great
lakes there's been freezing rain and
snow in the upper new england but the
good thing is rain has worked its way
off the east and southeast coast if
you're traveling there today so
hopefully no travel problems with
hang-ups at the airport so this snow
through the sierra will continue but
that will intensify as we get into
thursday and friday and rain will work
its way our direction 57 today clouds
and sunshine and then as we get into the
holiday weekend we're looking at a
slight chance of showers tomorrow
afternoon gusty winds ahead of the
system rain likely thursday night those
temperatures will bump up into the 60s
with those southwest winds still breezy
to windy on christmas eve so rain
thursday night into most of the day
christmas eve and then slight chances
left for santa friday night he's
delivering all those packages a slight
chance of showers christmas morning and
then we may see some sunshine or we'll
hang on to some clouds on christmas day
slight chances left for sunday morning
and again on monday and tuesday mornings
could even be cold enough to see a few
snowflakes somewhere